[Music]
hello I'm Brenda nester Bryan Smith nice
to have you here today's lecture is
going to be on the subject of my latest
losses so here I'm going to show a game
that was actually the last game I've
lost in the tournament game it was a
couple months ago my opponent or one
month ago it my opponent was Alexander
Linderman so this was the George
Washington Open in Virginia a five round
tournament this was the fourth round and
I stood very well coming into this game
with three out of three I had won in
round three against Tim or Gaurav with
black and this time I got second black
in a row so she was a lock and my
opponent a very strong player so going
into this game I was pretty happy where
the would have been pretty happy with
the draw it would leave me in a good
situation in the tournament I would get
white in the last round and I would have
already played my main competitors but
as it turned out I had a chance to win
but in the end it was kind of a
heartbreaking loss nevertheless had this
kind of thing happened many times I
played trust for a long time so I'm
starting to get better at dealing with
this kind of thing so I chose to play
the Bangko gambit the ran before I had
played King's Indian I don't know that
don't play the Bangko gambit that much
but I had some specific intention after
he took a six after if he took on a six
I had some specific intention but he
kinda sensed something I think and so he
played a relative sideline III so the
idea is that white can take back with
the bishop on b5 of course the pawn
would rather go to e4 in one move but
that's the price you have to pay for
having the bishop ready to develop so
here not really knowing the theory very
well since I haven't played the banker
much I didn't want to go for this
critical line Bishop takes B five or
eight takes b5 Bishop takes b5 Queen a5
check
Knight c3 and in Bishop e7 I had sort of
a vague recollection of this kind of
thing as being one of the main lines I
didn't know much about it so it would
have been dangerous to go into it
because there's more Theory here black
threatens to take on d5 pins the Knights
oh wait Chris Bishop d2 for instance and
then Queen b6 and ultimately blacks
gonna take the pawn on d5 and it's going
to become this kind of position where
white has a past a pawn on the on the
Queen side black has a potential mass of
center pawns which could be a factor
coming up but at the same time it's not
going to be so easy for black to advance
the center pawns whence black takes on
d5 eventually and they can come under
some pressure and it becomes a game
which it's practically well it's not so
easy for black and also I didn't know
the mmm I didn't know the theory very
well so I plead g6 just developing and
going into this kind of I knew that this
move is what can be played here and that
much I knew but I didn't know much much
more than that
so I Knight c3 he played Bishop g7
Knight of three okay castles so all
pretty normal now he played a four this
is typical move that white will play in
these positions because he for one thing
he might take back with this pawn and on
some later situation of course after his
rook is after it's no longer end but
also he prepares to play rook a3 with
the rook with the ropes got being
guarded and sometimes has a role on the
third-ranked
so here was kind of a tough moment for
me and I started getting in time
pressure in this game because I I
I was thinking a lot
so here I've think I spent maybe 15
minutes and I came up with a move that I
thought was very good and of course
later I looked up how the games of other
people have gone the theory let's say or
their games and almost everyone played
this move the reason was that if I just
play like in a typical Benko style it's
a d6 whites maybe play e4 but also he
could play other moves first but
basically I'm I'm gonna get to a
position where I I don't get the Norton
for instance normally in the Benko you
prevent the king white from castling you
have other kinds of things you can do
early on and here I'm not exactly
getting the place as much as as normal I
think of course the fact that white
spent two moves to play you Ford gives
me something but I wasn't so comfortable
with this position I thought white could
stamp out flex play
I wanted to play e6 but if I play e6 I
started calculating takes pawn takes and
then Queen d6 which is a little bit of
awkward move to face because I don't
have any good way of guarding my C pawn
maybe this is possible to play this way
but now I'll cue lated Queen a5 of
course Bishop d7 Queen takes c5 I don't
have enough compensation for two pawns
it looks like I calculated Queen a5 with
the idea that after takes there's 94
which is bad for white but it just plays
Bishop d2 and and now I don't have
anything and if Queen before it looks
like capturing this pawn is gonna be not
no not a good idea so this this didn't
work maybe black can take on b5 and then
Knight a6 and it says something to think
about but but it's it's better to play
the move I played which in those in in
all circumstances if I do play e6 the
bishops going to be well placed on b7
anyway normally you don't play this move
but only if it's in conjunction with
these six because otherwise the bishop
is not going to be well placed just two
facing White's pawn so he played now
rook a3
a typical move and I think his idea is
that in some cases well he wants to take
on b5 and one one move with his bishop
of course I'm not sure if rook e3 is the
best move but that's it looks like some
one one other pasta and other
possibilities many of the Dwight could
play is efore d6 I'm gonna play this
move and then you could try to keep pawn
on e6 rather on d5 rather than taking on
e6 and give me the center and a
bloomenfeld gambit type compensation for
the pawn then I need to get something
going here because the otherwise he
castles and he has an extra pawn and I
don't break down d5 then I I don't get
any compensation really or not enough so
I have to do something like this and now
he has to take with the bishop and I get
to check here there's some other moves
possible as well but and then you can
get the pawn back like this Knight g4 he
gives it back upon on e3 and it's a I
have the dark squared bishop but on the
other hand still the cramping pawn on d5
remains and he has the past a pawn it's
a double edged game this happened in his
some games I looked at but played rook K
3 so I go e 6 so now now the pawn on d5
is under his hack and he can't really
keep it he can't really keep it there
forever so he took on e6 I took back and
now the idea was Queen d6 then I have
Queen ca either now or first take on b5
I don't know but Queen c8 and I guard
the C pawn and then then I can chase the
Queen away with 98 and get to d5 move
yeah
still I think this was maybe maybe
better than what he played he just
played Bishop e2 because maybe he could
play that way and although he's he loses
time with his Queen I also lose some
time and I lose time with my knight so
it's a whole different game usually then
the Queen goes to g3 in that case but
he's played Bishop e2 so here I took on
b5 I wanted to resolve this situation
and now I was just had enough time I was
enough time to start worrying about a
takes b5 but I looked at this and I I
wanted to take on a 3 because this
although he has the two passed pawns
connected they're disconnected they're
the I mean I have the a 5 square so
they're this pawn structure is not the
puns are not so easy to push here of
course in a long term I just kill me but
they're not so easy to push here and I
can get some counter play and I also
have my own pawns in the center I have a
past C pawn and here of course I'm
threatening the night and if Bishop d2 I
take to say pawn but he has Queen to d2
and it was hard to find anything here I
couldn't exactly I mean I even though I
have some glimmer of tactics I can't
make anything work here so I was not
exactly sure I thought I might I might
just play d5 right away but this would
have been better for him I think than
what he did now he can trade rooks in
some case and while these pawns are
still doubled this pawn and b5 as a
standing threat for the rest of the game
I have compensation but I think this was
better than what he did but somewhat
surprising and Lenderman was playing
pretty quickly too he was taking a very
practical approach which was a total
opposite of how I played I was thinking
a lot and trying to find the best moves
and it it was he played a practical way
where he sort of give me attack but
challenged me to find a way to break
through and as I got into time pressure
okay so I he took on b5 were the knight
and now I went 94 sorry 94 which maybe
wasn't the most accurate I wanted to
take advantage of the knight move and
control c3 but probably the knight just
has to go but so maybe it was better to
start with d5 immediately and then maybe
94 in the future but I thing was I also
wasn't sure whether I was going to play
whether I was gonna play d5 at all at
this point I wanted to consider for
instance 94 what he castled I wanted to
consider somehow getting the knight to
be for maybe playing this in here and
playing Bishop d5 and some other setup
without d5 but it turned out not to be a
very very good so I ended up playing d5
anyway and I somewhat regretted my 94
it's still okay still good so here I
played b3
I think this move also might not have
been the best I was a little bit worried
about Knight to d2 because now my knight
either I have to exchange the knight
which I don't really want to do
every piece exchange helps him he has
less space he frees his position up a
little bit even though he has to take
Carly with it he has to take with a
queen because if I take because b2 pawn
is but then this helps him a lot I
didn't want to exchange this knight so
kind of really regretting the Knight e4
move but he didn't end up playing Knight
to e2 most like I would have retreated
the knight instill 92 it's not that
great here but he can play e4 and then
this is another another way of white
trying to free his position I guess I
probably play Knight to c6 because I'm
not gonna take on e4 and still a lot of
compensation but a lot more freedom for
white than he got in the game so I think
he should have done it he played b3
I played knight c6 Bishop d2 his eye his
idea was to clear the long diagonal of
pieces and sort of plays a very passive
defensive strategy but challenges me to
break through and it's so I played Queen
e7 this this was a point where I'm also
thinking for a long time wanted to play
d4 but takes and Bishop c4 wasn't really
what I wanted and I couldn't find
anything happening with a rook takes f3
on the long diagonal in those cases it
took me awhile to admit that I could
just that I needed to just build up with
non concrete moves like Queen e7 but
that's what identifies Queen e7 r okay -
so he stepped away from my Queens and
glanced and also he improved the
position of his of his rope a little bit
and now rook to d8 so I'm still just
developing the rook I wanted to find
something more concrete but time
pressure was approaching and I was I was
happy with the previous two moves now d4
is starting to become on come on the
agenda if I do that I not only create
past pawn which is quite dangerous it
gets stepped forward just to d3
also it supports a navy Knight to c3 in
some cases and it opens up the long
diagonal for my
my bishop to create threats on the
kingside and even though white has an
extra pawn you don't feel this pawn this
is just a standing threat for the rest
of the game but at this moment don't
feel that on he played rook see to a
good move he's creating little worries
in me in my position I have to watch out
for c5 I have to watch her when I play D
pops when I play d4 that he's that C
file is going to open up he's not trying
to do anything he's just waiting for my
my for me for me to do something and
from for me to commit somehow and ready
to then counter-attack as soon as I
create something change in the position
so here I play d5 I wanted to play d4
again I was calculating but somehow
something like this I can't quite
remember exactly it actually looks
pretty promising here but I didn't
didn't quite like it I don't want to
give this kind of counter place so I
continued to build up I play d5 here
which was not a movie that I always
wanted to play in fact but I I decided
that this was the best and at some point
I'm gonna tell also I could take on d2
of course taking this important artist
or a bishop but it also frees his
position a little bit probably he takes
with the through the night I suppose and
then he can try to know this was this
was pretty promising for black but I
think I was worried about such yeah yeah
I remember looking at this kind of thing
and now night before rook takes c5
Knight a - something like that but
didn't quite it wasn't quite wasn't
quite working queen a3 I guess anyway I
wanted to take the bishop but at the
same time I didn't want to free his
position I wanted to be ready when I
take the bishop to play e4 right away
afterwards so I play d5 here the other
there's also thought of g5 and previous
moves would have never quite achieved
anything for instance here no I'm not
getting g4 and exactly although this is
also even I can maybe sacrifice the pawn
g4 there was so many tempting
possibilities but time pressure was
starting to approach ultimate I play d5
okay so he played Queen c1 so again he's
stepping off the D file now and he's
threatening to pawn on c5 so the same
kind of thing if I take on D to c5 is so
I played rook c8 another move which I
it's I'm just preparing preparing action
here I'm ready to take on d2 and follow
up with you for so he played bishop he
won now saving his bishop and again I'm
now I played Knight to be four so I
attack his rook and he faces a tough
choice after this move this was I was
really starting to think now even though
I was quite low on time I don't remember
but I was using my time pretty in
practically is not in a very practical
way even though despite that I was
thinking probably I'm gonna win this
game if I can keep my nerves together
because he faces a really tough choice
if he takes on b4 I take back and this
is the kind of position where I think
that White's gonna I mean my moves
should be pretty easy because I'm
putting my knight in to c3 next I'll
take on c2 and then play rook c8 and
then put the night in to c3 and either
he takes giving me this extremely strong
past pawn held together by the bishop on
g7 which has no opponent and then I'm
gonna follow up most likely by e4 and I
can combine the the standing threat of
the pawn on c3 was pushed through in the
center and on the Kings side even so
it's very dangerous for him and I think
he made a great practical choice to play
wrote could be two but this is also not
the ideal move because now the rook has
sort of in the line of fire of my bishop
and it's a little bit passive so now is
now here still though there's no
immediate push forward d4 was not
exactly what I wanted yet Bishop c4 I
think and then maybe nicety too and he's
starting to this is definitely promising
for black but I decided to first play
King h8 to support this kind of thing
later now he goes Knight to due to a
very good move he needs to act because
d4 is going to be really strong now I'm
going to be following up with d3 and his
pieces are just too passive to to answer
this kind of thing so nights easy to
he'd he questions my knight on e4 so my
night I didn't want to trade again this
would free his position I want to leave
these pieces all cluttered here and the
rook also here so I definitely didn't
want to take on D to d4 would allow him
to exchange some pieces maybe d4 as
possible but I didn't really want to do
it yet so he took so I moved my knight
away I went Knight to g5 now my
intention is to play e4 and maybe I'll
take his rook but it's he might also but
I might not want to take it especially
without giving up my dark strip bishop
all his own dark squared Bishop is still
on the board but that's my plan he for
then then d4 is coming next and it's
White's facing just irresistible attack
so well White's bit played in this kind
of rope-a-dope strategy for his pieces
hunkering on the back rank but but he
can't just keep doing that forever
because it's so he now played a good
move f3 which was he had to play so at
least he has some answer to e4 and again
now I don't know about the exact time
situation was I don't remember but I
think I though there was a time control
move 40 and this is move 22 so I I was
probably below 10 minutes at this point
I'd really used a lot and he had a lot
of time because he was playing pretty
quickly I mean he had no 40 minutes or
something but it's just an estimate so
here I ended up playing e4 anyway and I
could continue building up with 96 but I
was not really satisfied by letting with
letting him play Bishop g3 or Bishop f2
I wanted to strike before he get starts
getting more pieces because I didn't
know exactly if I play 96 and maybe he
plays Bishop g3 let's say or Bishop f2
it might you know yeah Bishop g3 because
the e5 pawn is you know if I ever play
you for he starts having access to d6
and if I play d4 you get c4 so I felt
the time was right to strike with E for
so I did that and it's not so much that
I'm attacking his rook I was I didn't
want to take that rook especially when
you're getting low in time you don't
want to take the material I wanted to
get a strong attack so but it is also
part of other ideas so right now I want
to probably take on f3 and then this
pawn is hanging unless his Knight takes
in which case I get my knight in to e4
which is really bad for white that's one
of the things I also if he plays f4 I go
96 and now d4 is coming and this is this
is a position which White's not going to
be able to survive in practical game
this is too much so he played F takes e4
oops F takes e4 and now if I just take
back and try to keep a piece the problem
here the problem was he has Knight to d6
and all my pieces are under attack and
III is guarded by his queen so instead I
took with the pawn and it looks like
I've made my beautiful pawn structure
more ugly and that my first thought was
this wasn't a bad idea but then I
decided this is the only way forward and
the reason is this pawn is well now my
pawns are broken up right and he has the
c-4 square but now this pawn is
supporting pieces invading there and
it's backed up by this bishop it's gonna
be open opening up the bishop for
instance if the pawn captures on d3 so
my plan was simply next move I'm coming
into d3 and he's hardly gonna be honest
and the presence of that he's gonna have
to give up his LightSquared Bishop and
this Bishop is gonna be opened up and
I'm even gonna have some tactics like
Knight takes 3 a knight Age 3 check so
this was this was my plan and it was it
looked pretty promising and he has to do
something because there's so he goes
nice c4 he's got his own ideas of Knight
coming in to d6 so here very low on time
I faced a tough choice Knight f3 or 93
cuz it's one of those two moves I don't
want to take on B to notice this rook is
hanging but I'm not going to take that
roken unless at least I've exchanged off
this this would be a really naive move
because this position my king is in some
danger and he has a pawn already he's a
good pawn structure he's coming in with
a knight on d6 maybe Bishop also coming
up here it's it's a it would be
extremely naive to take that rook at
this point
so then site not eventually because I
didn't have much time at all but I I
played Knight f3 check which was yeah it
was a tough choice but 92 d3 I didn't
see really concretely he has to take it
I take back and I didn't really see
concretely how I'm for instance he has
this annoying move Knight B to D 6 and
now if I take I can I can but he has
this move and now he's trading a lot of
pieces and I still haven't well there's
a lot of threats and I didn't see
anything concrete there so I so I
decided to do this Knight f3 check which
is also I mean this move looks looks
better when you use it when you thinking
about it I think this move is actually
better practically speaking but I was
worried he was gonna play King gate 20
and while he was thinking I king h1 just
ignoring the night I can take my deal
was to take his Bishop and then take
here but this position while black is
better I am up the exchange but and
there's no dark sword Bishop for him but
it's still not so easy we get a position
similar to this in the game later but
this is a better version I think black
is much better and it's not it's not
that easy though and we long time but he
didn't do that to my my happiness he he
took with his Bishop now if he took with
the pawn this was this was pretty clear
I just take care and now the bishops
under attack if I take that I have my
dream position so he has to try to move
his Bishop but or if he takes on f3 this
is my dream position I'm down one pawn
still but his King is wide open and 93
as a threat the rook is also hanging in
Queen g5 in many cases and so on so if
if he take it so so he took with a
bishop
oh sorry so I was so G takes a feats if
he tries Bishop d1 trying to just say
okay I'm up a piece I have to prove or
something but it's not very hard to do I
come in with my knight here this is
extremely powerful Queen to d2 and then
for instance f2 check and this opens up
the long diagonal Bishop takes F to
Queenie 4 and this is just crushing but
I didn't see this during the game but it
it was pretty clear he couldn't he
wouldn't be able to get away there's
probably other ways to win here too
anyway he took with the Bishop on f3 and
I had hardly calculated this because I
assumed that he's not gonna play it but
now I had just a couple minutes and then
had to make a big decision so I take the
bird in the hand with Knight to d3 grab
his rook which I thought he might have
even missed wow I wasn't sure but he
think he thought for a little while on
Bishop takes f3 even thought it's
possible he missed it and just take the
rook without even giving up my dark
squared bishop or do I pursue the attack
by taking the Bishop on f3 and
unfortunately although I glimpse the
variation after take on f3 which well
show you in a second in a second and I
made the wrong decision because when
you're really low in time you sometimes
just want some clarity and I missed
something a little bit later although
I'm still better after Knight takes c3 I
took on f3 if I take on f3 it's a really
promising position of course if he takes
back and Bishop takes f3 transposes -
what would have happened if he took with
the pawn so here he was gonna remove my
knight and that's what I calculated for
brief second and I saw the move EV takes
g2 threatening the rook on f1 this
in-between move F takes G - he has to
take I take back now rook f1 check
winning the Queen as a threat so he has
to play rook f2 and I think I kind of
looked this far and I said well it's not
so clear let me take the exchange but
here of course it's this position now
this is when I so after the game I
started thinking about this among other
things and then I was having lunch just
because there's not enough time to go
and actually analyze the game certainly
didn't didn't open up the computer and
see when anything about
would the computer said or anything like
this I went to lunch before my next game
which is probably starting in like 20
more minutes and I started analyzing
this blind full blind was another player
there who was I am named regazzi and we
we started looking at this and he
suggests a move suggested them of
knights seated Issa I thought this was
probably just winning for black it's
just in general I mean this pawn on G
it's now equal material and I have a
pawn on g2 two bishops and his King is
open but it's not so simple for instance
Knight open 8c to d6 now he tries to
bother this Bishop and also Queen to c8
so I have to prove something here but he
found this remarkable idea Bishop h6
first of all attacking this pawn and so
the ideas the king is overworked it's
guarding g1 and is guarding e3 so I'm
threatening g1 or I'm also threatening
Bishop takes c3 so for instance Knight
takes b7 then g1 and wins his queen
because if Queen takes g1 Bishop takes
c3 or if King takes you and also Bishop
takes c3 where I could start with this
should take c3 here so what if white
tries to be clever here after Bishop h6
there's no other way apparently to
defend it by me you can play Knight to
c4 but then tonight is just force back
and I have well we'll see a similar
position but with black having less time
but let's suppose Queen to be to check
first moving the Queen away and then
taking the bishop so now if I take the
pawn on e3 he removes this pawn on g2
it's not guarded anymore and there's no
there's no G 1 because the Queen's not
unsee one to be forked but black has an
incredible move that we that he pointed
out blindfolded
Queenie for just keeping the pawn alive
just long enough and blacks down a piece
but there's no checks Bishop takes c3 is
coming and of course have white guards
the pawn with the Queen black still take
on e3 and then quit and then she won so
like let's take Queen to d4 I still play
this and then g1
and win the Queen and black wins so that
was a really remarkable variation let's
suppose he didn't do so night-night this
suppose he's the other night this way
there's no this night as well guard this
pond is well guarded but on the other
hand he doesn't get the threat of this
so this time I can just move my bishop
and I think this should be a pretty
solid pretty steady win although it's
not obvious so let's suppose now now he
plays a5 his Knights can't move if he
for then I can just take here nice to
take with the night because there's
always otherwise it's not guarded and
then I would take care and then Bishop
d4 is coming so that's that's not good
so he has to play let's say he goes a5
or any other move that doesn't
immediately create some sort of threat
then I get my then I have the time to
get my Queen here these this battery is
very strong it's still equal material
I'm stalking his a pawn and I looked at
this position this morning a little bit
a 6 it's a funny position because well I
mean it's losing for white but the
immediate there's no immediate that a
obvious way to make progress except
there's also nothing white can do at all
Queen has to guard f1 always Knight has
to guard I mean the Knights have to
guard each other
if this Knight moves away for instance
somewhere then I can usually take on c4
in some way and if he takes this way I
get a passed pawn if he takes the Queen
usually there's well I mean maybe the
knight can move sometimes but there's
also then Bishop h6 and Bishop takes e4
also coming so basically white can't do
much and so that it started looking and
maybe H simple h5 and black and just
advanced the pawns on the Kings side and
White Queen can't really move anywhere
and the nice can't really do much the
eight pawns is not going anywhere it can
go to a7 but I just keep the g5 and so
on just push the pawn to g4 h4g three
takes and then h3 and there's also a
plan to bring the bishop to h3 which
white has to watch for also has to be
ready to meet it with night Queen e1 and
Knight to d2 guarding this and guarding
f1
it's it's a losing position for white so
that that was seemingly you know okay
look it's hard decision make so anyway I
went Knight to t3 Queen moved as today
saved the Queen I took on b2 and of
course if he just takes back with a
knight then I take f3 and I have the
same sort of position but I also have an
extra exchange and basically white can
resign now but and so I but I didn't
have time to glance at this move he just
plays this and so it's not so simple I'm
up the exchange but he still has the
structural advantage as the outside past
pawn and it's not going to be clear what
blacks plan is so I had to make a very
difficult choice now was very little
time on the clock and I went for the
initiative this time Knight to d3 I
could take on c4 Bishop takes c4 and
blacks up the exchange for one pawn and
has a much better position but again
what's blacks plan it's not that easy
and white can has the standing threat of
the a pawn the night coming into d6
this kind of thing so I decided to play
Knight to d3 so if he takes the knight
it's gonna be at the cost of opening up
my bishop it was a very debatable
decision but that's what I chose he went
now Bishop g3 so for instance if Bishop
takes d3 takes Queen takes and now
Bishop e4 was worth considering for him
but this looks like now I'll take on f1
rook f8 and with my bishops and maybe
Bishop h6 and so on bishops and the
extra exchanged probably black should be
close to winning but he played Bishop g3
trying to invade on d6 threatening
Bishop d6 so I took it show takes F one
rook to d8 so stepping aside from Knight
to d6 he went in Knight to d6 I went
Bishop d5 and here it was now time for
him to take the knight on d3 because
otherwise I'm just going to continue
improving my position and it might take
on c4 as well in which case the knight
is solid and I'm probably gonna push my
each pawn this was a move I wanted to
play very soon making room for my King
and also to play h4 and further create
some cramping on his Kings side some
more threats
so he so I went Bishop so he went he
took upon Queen take upon takes Queen
takes and now I took here so that he now
has two points for the exchange but the
cost of getting into a very serious pin
here but the problem is now what can I
do to actually to use this he's pushing
his a pawn which is going to be a
diversion he has two pawns for the piece
I mean for the exchange it's not you
know it's not so easy so I want to trade
off this Bishop Jin g3 I want to play
Bishop e5 but of course this losses
after takes a knight of seven so I
played Bishop of six and now I'm down
probably to less than a minute for sure
King just seven is the idea is to play
King g7 and only then at some point well
probably first rook to g7 so there's no
Knight of five and also Bishop e5 I
didn't see how he's gonna free himself
but I didn't really know what was gonna
happen there's no time and that really
calculates so he played h3 which he has
to play at some point and here I went
King g7 which was probably not the most
accurate turns out there's another way
for me to make progress here which was
the start was work to d7 and then for
instance a5 Queen e6 and the idea is
Bishop e7 and
I probably have to first play King g8
also I know a six there should be seven
yeah if Queen c3 then I guess King g8
and still yeah I mean it's still not it
doesn't seem so clear also King g8
mm-hmm I need to be five but this pawn
is hanging so now I can take that one
yeah in this case at least if he doesn't
play a six then I can go King g7 first
but there's a basically the idea of rook
d7 and then Bishop e7 - of course if I
start with yeah if I if I start with
this and yeah I guess I could also do
that but I have to play rook d7 at some
point here he has this this check oops
sorry
check
anyway so there was that but anyway I
played King g7 which was the natural now
he played Queen to defy which I was very
surprised I'm not sure if he blundered
something here he actually did twice and
scheme Queen DD Phi which kind of
surprised me I'm not sure if you might
have missed the not the next move but
the one after that or she was he just
thought his position was bad after 85
but I think after 85 he's actually okay
I play rook d7 I still can't play Bishop
e5 because takes and then Knight a5
discovering attack on the rook so I had
to play rook d7 first and then here
Bishop e5 for instance still is not so
clear because he he has the first night
of five I didn't I didn't see this
during the game this was just my plan
and I thought it was going to be good
winning for black but he actually has
this move and then this and I have to
guard f5 and in Queen c3 and this is not
a very clear position at he has an
outside passed pawn and I actually it's
fine for a white but instead he maybe I
could instead of playing Bishop e5 of
course I can delay it I can play aged
five and I'm not sure what White's doing
but he can sort of sit there and I'm not
sure what
anyway he he he played Queen d5 which
gave me this pawn and now he started to
think probably because he missed it
maybe after Quinta that after King H - I
have Bishop d4 but he played King H -
anyway because if Bishop of - and at
this point I remember I just had second
stuff his nurse move 36 but there's you
know there's a five-second increment or
maybe it was 10 seconds I don't know but
Bishop of - I hey I was I can play just
oh sorry I was going to play Queen you
so Queen e5 is good also but Queen e7
was a simple thing because now the
bishop and if he goes back there's a g3
it's pointless I can go Bishop d4 check
then but if Bishop takes c5 I have a
force when Queen e1 king h2 and then
Bishop e5 check and then
his king is made it so instead he played
King age to Bishop D for threatening
mate and maybe he intended this but then
but now after King the King moves
somewhere for instance King h8 knight of
seven check King J there's no more good
checks age six is under blacks control
and maid is threatened on g1 so the
knight on f7 is vulnerable now I'm gonna
after age four I'm gonna hit it with I'm
gonna getting a temp was Rick a fade so
he played age four right away but maybe
it was worth it throwing in this queen
b7 check but he played h4 and here was
really low time on the clock the thing
was I was looking at that queen b7 check
and some other stuff and you know you're
when you have just seconds left to make
three moves or four to four moves it's
it's a little bit disorienting and I
couldn't quite make mice I knew who's
gonna play h4 but I couldn't quite make
myself calculate and it's nevertheless I
found the right move of Queen e7 which
was if because Queens g1 King age 3 I
don't have anything here for instance
here I would even lose Queen f7 King age
6 and now Knight a5
if King age 5 then g4 mate and if G
takes h5 f 5 then Queen f6 and Queen g5
mate
of course I didn't consider to putting
my pieces off sides like that but I
still it was it was hard to I thought
Queen d7 was just okay I just need to
make some sort of move but it turned out
to be by far the best move here so I
I've grabbed a pawn and I've gotten back
to defend everything now he played a 5
here and at the time I was more
concerned about h5 but it turns out a
fight
h5 doesn't doesn't really isn't really
good but in order to win I would have to
find only move so just with a crook f8
I think I was I'm not sure if I was
gonna play that or not but a five and
then rook f1 I can come in with the rook
just in time so for instance if a six I
get Queenie three and then if Queen B
seven King age six and if some King
takes h5 Queen d5 g5 but this would have
been really hard to calculate in time
pressure to go in on that I'm most
likely that wouldn't have happened but
it's it's hard to so he played a five
and I wanted to stop h5 so I played h5
myself which was it's funny because this
morning I was preparing for this and I
couldn't remember all my thoughts or
anything like that I ran it through the
computer and it says every other move is
0 0 0 and h5 is the only winning move
here straight for some reason of course
if from my point of view I just want to
play this move because I want to stop
age 5 and I want to make some space for
my king if I play trick f8 he's just in
time here and now he has night b5
because without the pawn on h5 I don't
have rook f5 so a strange thing it turns
out that in some cases his age upon
going there could be bad from so I
played h5 he went a6 and here I played
now Bishop f6 again I was just this was
moved 39 and I just wanted something
where at least I have I didn't I
couldn't keep the whole situation my
head what's going on here
the problem with I wanted to play rook
to d7 to guard the 7th rank but I did
see that he goes a 7 and Knight c8 and
then he and then he wins the there's any
wins that rook and no well I guess it's
he wins the exchange but it's it's
pretty good still equal ish but anyway I
don't want that so
turns out that my bishop of six now this
wasn't as good it wasn't good and of
course it wasn't as good but King aged
seven is actually winning for black and
the reason is strangely enough this
position is apparently su Guang of
course King aged seven is a move you can
either you can make and if I had more
time I probably would have made it
I've moved my king away from potential
problems with Bishop e5 which we'll see
and also Knight a5 in some cases and but
the funny thing is is actually sucks
wrong in this position if the Queen
moves for instance Queen c6 then I make
progress by Queen e6 I think
yeah yeah so and then Bishop e5 is
coming yeah something like that
basically he does and if he moves his
King to the back rank for instance King
h1 then rook to d7 it's possible now
just inching forward and now if a7 then
I think then I can take in and there's a
check on a1 if he goes Knight CA so
that's that difference if he meanwhile
continues to wait King each to then I
get my queen in because I've managed to
cover the seventh rank and it managed to
stop Knight a5 check so I get my queen
in and and black is black is than
winning here so well it's really hard to
see this I play Bishop of six Queen
takes e5 so he got that important pawn I
took this pawn this should be five check
which also another thing is King age
seven would prepare this kind of thing
and so I can't play Bishop of six which
is what I would like to play which I did
see but when before the time control is
now move 41 but of course because he has
Knight f5 check and my Bishop is pin so
I lose my queen she takes her five Queen
67 so I played King age seven and now we
have an extra thirty minutes I mean with
on the move before we had an extra
thirty minutes but it's this extremely
complicated position it looked like a
like it was probably going to end in a
draw one way or another but I so now
he's thinking for a long time and he
played Queens e5 which I was very
surprised to see and I didn't expect
this move but it looks okay I was
looking at a seven and then I first
looked at Bishop to f2 and I was
calculating this varies from Queen takes
F to Queen e5 check Queen g3 Queen takes
two three check rook to King T and can I
make a safe draw by forced before Singh
because these are all forcing the bishop
of two he's forced to take it he's
forced to play this move and if I trade
Queens kind of is that what happens in
the sending of course I can't win it but
I was calculating whether this leads to
draw rook e8 night b5 and then I was
kind of have to get my king over there
g 5 c 5 king just 6 c 6 king I also had
to play G 5 to keep his King out I was
calculating this and I didn't
immediately see in it but it the whole
thing gave me the creeps because his
pawns are very dangerous the knight
there's all kinds of Forks and things
like that and my rook is stuck and and I
was I didn't see a win but I was not
going to play this and turns out there
actually was now he has this he wins the
rook with a 8 and and I and I and I
can't draw the ending also if King g6 a
a takes a king c6 I guess his King comes
around and he's in time king of three
King e for king of five and so on well
I'm taking the Knight and my Kings too
far away so I wasn't gonna do that but I
think what he was afraid of was rook e8
because now his knight is pinned so he
can't protect the eighth one if he loses
a pawn he's in great danger of losing
the game so Bishop d4 and then maybe
Bishop g5 and this looks dangerous for
white because now I'm threatening to
come in there and he has to play g3 but
there's nothing anything concrete here
for black so I think that's what he was
afraid of in case I saw this then and I
decided well I'll probably play that he
played Queen d5 which was most likely a
good move and this provoked me also I
thought after this well I have Bishop f2
which looks like a move you gotta you
have to play I mean this is Queen h4 is
coming it forces him to play g3 and then
his King is more exposed my initial my
plan had been to play Bishop of 6 and
break the connection and try to
undermine the night and I saw here then
when he played Queen d5 I thought for a
while I thought for a while about Bishop
of 6 and I saw that it led to a draw but
I I couldn't resist making the move
Bishop F - even though strangely I
didn't see anything there that was
concrete I just thought that this move
has to be the best move and so I played
it but Bishop is was a mistake in Bishop
f6 was was the way to go and I thought
he would probably take on f6 Queen takes
d6 probably's only dangerous for me
because
then he goes a5 and Bishop d4 bit should
be 65 and so on
like after trade of Queens something
like this happens here this is forced
Bishop before the next fish should be 6
and c5 and my King comes over but I mean
I can't win that so I thought Queen
takes f6 and then a 7 and now I thought
I have to give perpetual check with
Queen h4 because otherwise I can't do
anything I can't take on d6 because he
makes a new queen at least that's not
you know rook takes d6 he he makes a new
queen and I'm definitely name there so
have to give Perpetual he also actually
was saying after the game that he was
gonna play Bishop before Bishop which
also leads to draw but White has to find
it now was gonna die Diaz to play g5 all
that actually I have Bishop g7 now when
blacks better again yeah I was looking
at this now Queen h4 is a threat and the
king is now safe so it's I think black
has the chances there but g5 and then he
is he was gonna play a7 he said and then
this leads to because I can't go to King
g7 Knight a5 check and I have I have to
again dodge the checks
I can't go to f8 because he Queens the
pawn and then I I can only be worse and
down upon still though it's perpetual
but I played Bishop f2 so now he played
g3 which was the only move but somehow I
thought well ok now the king is open I'm
gonna play age 4 I saw this and I he has
to take because everything else is not
good for white I'm threatening to take
with the bishop and so on or take with
the pawn also and here I mean I realized
that there were problems but I was still
was just
somehow not thinking very concretely I
took with the Queen I could backtrack
with Bishop takes h4 and the positions
still probably about equal because he's
not gonna be able to Queen his pawns and
keep his King out of perpetual check and
I'm still getting ready to go Bishop of
six and I think it's still gonna lead to
a draw somehow but I took with the Queen
and I realized this was a problem
because the Queen and Bishop really are
in terrible coordination these two
pieces often don't work very well
together and now I have a problem that
my my cleanness to guard the bishop and
I can't really use my that's either
piece and he's got a counter threat now
if Queen f7 and so if rukh f8 he has
Queen b7 also so that's bad if I go rook
f8 Queen b7 and he's getting there first
he's gonna take my route for instance
you know maybe even made somehow but I I
thought initially that there might be
some perpetual but of course here I
couldn't the king whose runs away and I
don't have enough pieces left so I had
to play rook to d7 and now right now I
regretted playing Bishop of 2 going into
this and he played a strong move Queen
f3 threatening my Bishop and also ideas
of coming in maybe to f8 or something at
some point so here now I was already
starting to get low in time of the
second time control and I started to
lose it pretty much which happens after
this kind of turn of events
I played Bishop to c5 which might have
been the which is the best move probably
after the game he said to Bishop D for
me analyzes this is interesting because
we looked at this line takes it takes
there I mean this is the idea is to get
my Bishop back with gain of time and
then this is the point Queen g5
I can't take on d4 because Queen age 3
that was one of the things that my rook
is so Queen g5 now if Queen g3 I trade
Queens and rook takes and now this
happens a 6 or a 7 I have to play this
move this would be six he has to do that
in order to push a C pawn I come here
and then it's a race who's getting there
and it turns out I get there just in
time and it's a draw I mean those ways
to make a draw there so but however the
question is if he doesn't play Queen g3
what if he plays King f1 and do I have
perpetual here and I started looking at
this now I don't know I looked at this
with someone else after its the idea is
that if I may be here his King is one
step closer and I might be losing this
ending I don't know but it's hearts it's
really hard to figure out if there's
also it would be very dangerous for him
to play this way there for instance is
rook e8 Queen B - there's lots of
different checks that would be extremely
dangerous for white so most likely Queen
g3 and it would be a lead to a draw but
I played Bishop c5 which is still okay
but he goes 94 and now I totally lost it
here because I I I was obviously White's
threatening Knight of six very serious
threat the bishops hanging in somehow I
just hallucinate it was very tired if
Bishop d7 Queen f7 and I'm gonna I'm
gonna lose here because here there's
lots of lots of ways to win for instance
Queen g7 and Knight e3 friend Queen
takes you six and so and this other
stuff too
yeah so also Bishop g7 there's but
anyway so that can allow Queen f7 and so
I I saw move rookie seven but I that
there's night of six and I just kind of
panicked and King aged six losses to
this but as it turns out there's nothing
actually here better than just taking
back the exchange for white what can
white to here I'm threatening to take
his his his Bishop I've got my
it's almost done I know I know
so it turned out that there's nothing
really better than just taking back the
exchange with Knight to g4 check now I
have to take the bishop because
otherwise Bishop of six so I have to for
instance King g7 Bishop of six so I have
to take the bishop and then check Queen
to two and Queen d4 and I don't think
y-you can win this position we looked at
the Queen the queen is really well
placed the pawns are both held by the
bishop the knight is under control more
or less of the Queen the dark square
approaches to the black King are covered
so I think and I can't see anything
that's any anything better than that
Knight to g7 will lead to the same thing
rook takes I guess I don't have anything
else but it's same position and I don't
see what else white can do because if
the Queen goes somewhere I have clean up
too I start making my own threats at
queen g5 also as a threat and rook takes
e5 and so on so amazingly however I come
in the course I got confused and very
tired after a long game I got confused
here and I just played rookie 7
forgetting my bishop was under attack so
he took on c5 of course and now now I
and now I obviously if Queen g5 Queen g3
and
there's no more check I mean 22 the King
goes to age 3 easily gets out of the
check so it's so I took on c4 and then I
resigned because I saw that he's he's
going Queen age 3 and and for instance
Queen Queen 8 shade and click Queen g7
and so taking the rook and so on so I
resign there so unfortunately drops the
rook at the end but I thought it was a
really fascinating game and I was upset
of course to lose this game but I was
able to recover kind of since I've done
this kind of thing so many times and
Anna managed to win the last game so
which was a really tough game - my
opponent was about 2300 and really kept
finding the only the only moves to
defend and and somehow I was able to
hold pulled it together and finally win
in the end
so I finished the tournament on a good
note so I hope you enjoyed this sorry it
hasn't been so interactive I just kind
of had the attitude of I guess that it
was a more it was a recording any
questions yeah okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]